here's an honor it's very rare we have a
guest who is on a stamp character killed
not yet please let me put on my glasses
how much does this stamp go for 1 pence
[Laughter]
you don't know you and your email
discuss your movie called the pose and
then a worthy and the regatta was his
own post box got a picture of that this
is where is this this is in Watford in
half a [ __ ] nothing how do we know it's
yours I don't have to my names on it I
don't know but you know what you I know
that's the newspaper
I'm tightening as well we're very proud
of you he's only two belts away from
total world domination but you are
actively looking for a cool boxing name
because I haven't got one No
so it's Anthony AJ Joshua right now you
can say that yeah Anthony AJ yeah sure
that's your name
that's my but have you tried any cool
names
honestly big Josh they cool my dad big
Josh I'm big Josh I don't know man
mailbox Josh no deliver
[Applause]
Bombay's
that'd be good
[Applause]
[Music]
you